hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to ultimate epic battle
simulator now I've never had a game that
people requested more fervently than
this one and if you understand the
concept between totally accurate battle
simulator I'm sure we can all understand
the concept behind this one I actually
have never played this before and I've
never even seen it but I already know
what's going on I'm going to put a whole
bunch of stuff onto the field and make
them clash at each other and hopefully
something gets something out of someone
oh my festive oh ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
Santa really Santa oh that's awesome
this is the [ __ ] Abbott Santa right
and II just hope for this new wave you
word for that oh god how many can you
put oh my god would that work they're
gonna work horse - just one just one
Santa because that's woman who is this
gonna work
oh oh oh oh no what have I done
oh oh nine frames per second oh god ok
it is best
oh my god where's it wickers Santa ha ha
ha ha Heinlein get out of there
I think Santa was over thickness in the
lake I stand in the lake oh my god
well [ __ ] you okay you're going to be
okay
saying I don't think you're gonna be
okay I severely overestimated the
ability for my computer to process this
sound has got wait here been till on
until they reach him or something did it
jump it along in three frames a second
oh I hate life oh ho ho
god damn it my wife run it in it uh
looks possessed this way I can
right-click the possessive what the hell
is all about oh god it's so janky ah
Santa be waddling over there eventually
what are the zombies on fire some people
didn't come out of the zombies oh god
that's so unplayable ah can i attack
consented okay okay I think Santa did
something Santa Cana flail around for a
little bit I think that was Santa's
method of telling those zombies what for
open unit rally rally yeah was my
bastard dead
my [ __ ] oh god I'm complaining it a
multiple personality syndrome duh
alright door to door to door don't mind
Sanna Sanna don't mind
nobody alright I'll be right back once
these forces meet each other which is
is very Kreuzberg okay they hear the
screams of the Damned
what the haha I know I'm not playing
this right but oh I got it I thought my
computer could handle a little more than
this I'm actually I'm shocked that my
computer can handle this at all
well I'm just gonna start flailing as
best I can and hope for the best
I'm not flailing anymore but I could
flail just a little harder than the
football it's still Christmas is that
what you said I'm gonna get you I'm not
gonna lose it yeah this is so sad
this is the job Oh God
yep zombies are victorious who was it a
super-tough she's lacking so much I
would turn a turn the return to potato
quality and hopefully [ __ ] get a lot
of these [ __ ] on the field with
jizzy you see there's a thousand of
these guys ranked shape oh no that means
world of thieves with city of los guru
that's nice okay how do I rotate these
guys right click the draw
oh okay so they're coming over them
about the hills here Santa's are gonna
meet meet him on the beaches coming up
through here you guys are coming up
through here yeah you're gonna attack
the bulgar attack this maybe see if this
works any better on potato crawl because
they [ __ ] me fit off a date equality
hell yeah oh we got a moderate 14 oh no
hang on
my webcam fruit that's a completely
different problem there we go I'm back
now okay hi oh god guys sorry nothing
broke there that that's totally normal
hello all right get a de leeuw do over
there I guess whatever ha ha ha ha the
enemies are all [ __ ] she just you're
gonna die so hard you're gonna die so
hard
Sana's oh man it'll be [ __ ] it's
working out quite well actually honestly
ha
haluska Pooky Pooky ha Bisky boskie woo
well we have some dead Santa's so that's
the thing I'm cool actually
I practically really cool I mean
obviously the Santa's are not going to
win this but from a sheer scale
magnitude of this thing like the fact
that my computer which is pretty good
but not like a supercomputer by any
means is able to render this battle I'm
impressed
that's actually pretty impressive I got
it made that's pretty cool I'm pretty
cool that's pretty cool that's pretty
cool oh god that's a lot of zombies
okay maybe 50,000 is a bit excessive is
there like a their time controls to this
[ __ ] I'm just going to exit the menu
here
I'm gonna get rid of that carnage turn
back up to high quality and start this
on more reasonable more reasonable
ventures let's go actually um medium
medium [ __ ]
all right screw festive the US soldier
versus fantasy orcs giant ogre's uh-huh
I always like me some giant ogre's all
right let's do a modest thousand
birthdays 250 is that fair that seems
fair seems fair
they've even got guns probably if
they're real like World War two soldiers
I would imagine that their guns go great
oh I'm getting so many frames Oh God
look god you can't even imagine how many
frames I'm getting whoo okay go for it
ha ha ha ha how are you not shooting
your own man oh my god you're aiming
right at his head if you're bathing
directly and they're all aiming it
directly in their head so I guess it's a
firestorm that is being spread
that is amazing either going down to oh
my god
well this is a decisive victory this by
sheer range alone twig and I got the
strategy all right I'm gonna go way up
this way no one's gonna know nothing
[Music]
oh no I think they spotted me oh not a
single one made it not a single one not
a single one wow that's pretty cool I
gotta cool it pretty cool I'm brittle oh
I saw a timescale up there so alright
okay I like this I'm gonna set up
something it's gonna be a rainy day
I thought the cracker noon it be hi noot
noot all over the place we're gonna get
an avalanche Canyon it's going to be an
assault from two friends we got our
shooter shooters here so we got the
ogres coming the long way around there
they're gonna flank them they're gonna
flank them from over here they're gonna
flank them they're gonna flank him it's
a smaller smaller attack squad 150 of
them and then we got another got a team
coming in from animals chickens penguins
kangaroo we got thousand kangaroos a
thousand strong coming up through the
pass never know when they're coming you
never know I think guys come straight
out of that way and then and then also
remains in grease Oh what just just one
wild man one crazy screaming wild man
coming in from the other flank he's out
of his goddamn Gordon never even in his
five should he be in this battle but
there is just like a frickin idiot some
oh it's beautiful oh it's beautiful
beautiful look at the ogres waiting in
desert but the ogres aren't who I'm
rootin for I'm earning for these
soldiers who absolutely should not be
here where's that crazy man what there
he is
oh there is
I'm a crazy guy Wow I will come get you
ah all these [ __ ] guys was your boomer
sticks well I've got my ax in my big old
hitting stick here I've never shown you
what for I'm a wild man oh and where's
my kangaroos where's my kicker
where's mccann guru knees there's the
rooty tooty kangaroo knees oh yeah there
they are
I realize now that I vastly outnumbered
all the other guys it's just perfect
what have I done
go for it go for everybody yeah okay oh
they're adorable they look like rats for
purple oh there is my wild man ah crazy
I'm coming for you whoa wild and next so
where's where's my wild man nobody you
know I did funny boy oh my god you did
he made his wild man cuz I counted
myself as more than one oh I'm wild and
crazy oh oh
many soldiers are unstoppable well
you're getting a little too full of
everybody I think you're about to get
full
yeah maybe not dude giant ogre's in data
no idea what running is all about yep
they're dead the Kangaroos bed Oh
Gators are tearing people up oh [ __ ]
they got speed on this side
oh-ho-ho and too busy filing in one by
one
all right look about the timescale here
slow mo baby epic whoa that's P to
toggle okay way okay key none the twice
nah well it's gonna take a while to kill
all those kangaroos I think somehow yeah
I think somehow the wild men who the
real winner of all this a poor guy is
porcel lost to the winds slums to the
winds forever oh you will be remembered
sweet friend hush much sweet beautiful
for hush hush now hush
it'll be okay now your wild and free in
your dreams oh I'll be a healthy baby oh
I got my hinder stick I got my ass oh
and everything to kill meaning all the
things that can kill which was
technically nothing less okay I'm a
winner in my mind ah wild that's what
he's like a where's the one kangaroo
where's the one Kanger there's one
kangaroo missing I have no idea where
we're gonna kick oh [ __ ] the here we are
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh my
god horrifying
alright whatever oh they hunted them the
last kangaroo like an animal Oh rats
sweet prison [ __ ] you think
they're gonna get a political oh god I'm
sorry about that okay oh boy
and even got a Doppler effect on this
sumbitch on the menu so that is epic
battle the ultimate epic battle
simulator very different so I a lot of
you guys have requested this but I can
see why it's fun now I can see why it's
fun so let me know what you think of how
I did down the comments below how did I
do that wrong did you not think I did it
perfectly right and I found the true
champion the one wild man the true hero
this game wild beyond your farthest
dream so thank you everybody so much for
watching I really do appreciate it this
was actually a lot of fun a lot more fun
nothing feat so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]